tél
[Musique]
chaque jour
le signer je suis chaque jour pour
chaque département
mais pas les prix mais également les
crimes sur papier blanc
la mesure bonne journée
et on est surpris enfin moi je suis
surpris du respect
aujourd'hui des consignes qui montre que
manifestement les citoyens ont pris
conscience de la nécessité d'une action
individuelle au profit de un effort
collectif pour pouvoir arriver à
maîtriser cette crise sanitaire autrui
alors je constate moi avec satisfaction
aujourd'hui en se déplaçant que les
personnes commencent à respecter les
intervalles il faut qu'on soit bien bon
mètre de distance 1 m 56 encore mieux et
il faut vraiment se laver les mains tout
le temps et être conscient aussi
commencé à réfléchir à sa vie
quotidienne
mais le forces de l'ordre se répondent
présentes j'ai discuté avec elle sera
tracé
elles répondent présentes
aussi pour faire en sorte que ces
mesures de confinement soit respectée
s'ils perdent en marche
il est en fait
[Musique]